ich habe sechs freunden von mir sechs
fragen gestellt die sie beantwortet
haben ohne dass ich mitbekommen habe und
ich werde diese fragen jetzt auch selbst
beantworten die sache ist die fragen
sind nicht nur nett dh es kann super gut
sein dass mir jetzt leute sagen was sie
an mir nicht mögen ich muss dann jetzt
damit klar kommen aber das ist der reis
vom video und deshalb bin ich auch so
super aufgeregt okay die erste frage
lautet direkt wie sportlich bin ich ich
würde ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich
manchmal ein ziemlicher körper klaus
sein kann wird sagen ich habe so eine
gewisse grund sportlichkeit ich bin
eigentlich so ein bisschen faul und
gemütlich was sport machen angeht alle
fragen müssen auf einer skala von 1 bis
10 beantwortet werden und ich glaube ich
würde mir selbst wenn meine
sportlichkeit mit 7,5 geben oder 07.07
ich würde mir eine 7 geben okay lass uns
anhören was die anderen sagen ich bin
echt aufgeregt als erstes kelly wie
sportlich ist max passieren aber nicht
so unsportlich wie ich erst irgendwo
dazu müssen würden sagen okay kelley
hatten wir auch nur sieben gegeben nicht
so sportlich wie sebastian das stimmt
sebastian ist halt schon seit jahren
regelmäßig im fitnessstudio ich bin
dafür viel zu faul so max geht zum sport
er hat eine sportliche statur um
sportlich aber mensch das heißt ja nicht
ist also max geht ja nicht so regelmäßig
ich werde meine sieben ansätzen glaube
ich kraft wir sind schon mal alle was
das erste angeht gleich also ich glaub
eins bis zehn bisher auf so alle
menschen überhaupt in deutschland wo
sowas da also ein system der
uni-professor mentaler zeiten zählen das
sportwissenschaften oder 6 ich habe
schon gedacht sebastian ist
wahrscheinlich erkennt mich am besten
und erst am ehrlichsten mit sechs gibt
dann ja okay dann muss hier zu leben
die hat mein leben genommen
4 das schmerzt schon ein bisschen muss
ich sagen aber sie hat er recht damit
dass ich faul bin bei den wenigsten
sachen und bin ich kontinuierlich daran
ja dann fährt die und halt für mich hat
aber ich friere ist das trio die sich
das überhaupt traut so was zu sagen war
super viele menschen wenn dann einfach
so lieb sein und bin einfach irgendwas
sagen aber nur vier vermutlich ziemlich
genau so sportlich wie ich wenn wir
sport machen nur zusammen sport machen
geben wägen würde ich sagen bei
momentaner auslastung 6 das stimmt
überhaupt nicht das ist verliebt von
dave guckt euch diesen lieblichen man an
wer das gerade sein aber ich bin nicht
so sportlich wie dave davis dave macht
so einen backflip aus dem stand wenn ich
das machen würde würde ich mir alle
knochen fünfmal brechen und können nie
wieder laufen also no drop
es schmeichelt mir wave du bist auf
jeden fall sportlicher du bist doch
keine 6 für techno achtgeben
wahrscheinlich geht ja auch so eine
grund sportlichkeit jesus christus ich
dachte es wäre runtergerutscht scheinbar
fast das handy runtergefallen
das war schon mal genug fläche wie
sportlich ist das sieht nicht gut aus
teilweise sieben teilweise ein 4-3-3 mit
3 so schlimm war es noch gar nicht aber
ich kann verstehen dass sie anna sagt
teilweise mit 7000 der 3 es gibt so
manche sachen die kann ich richtig gut
und bei anderen sachen bin ich halt
übels ein idiot ich würde sagen so ein
durchstart vielleicht gibt mir insgesamt
fünf ich bin halt einfach nicht so
sportlich könnte es bestimmt sein aber
dafür bin ich zu faul nehmen jetzt auch
so schreibe es in die kommentare kommen
wir zur nächsten frage wie kommt findet
bin ich mit dem anderen geschlecht also
wie gut kann ich mit mädels reden das
ist echt schwierig teilweise bin ich da
so voll dolly würde wahrscheinlich
probleme haben einfach so ein mädel was
ich so super hübsch winter auf der
straße anzusprechen so was ja eigentlich
schon voll dumm ist soweit warum sollte
man es nicht tun ich bin auch nicht so
ganz super
schlimm darin ich würde aber sagen ich
kenne leute die sind also über kraft
drin ist dann würde ich mir jetzt
einfach mal eine pessimistische sechs
selbst geben
ok kelly gibt mir nachts tatsächlich
dafür aber sie hat schon recht so ich
habe jetzt gerade einfach selbst daran
gedacht dass es nur darum geht mädels
sonst kriegst du zu klären aber ich
meine ich bin ja mit wem befreundet
obviously das ist eigentlich ja da
stelle ich mich eigentlich nicht so dumm
an vielleicht war auch nur sechste
pessimistisch aber nach wenig klingt gut
also kann ich mich nicht beschweren
da würde ich so liebe setzen also mit
männern dann weil er ist ja eine frau
perfekt immer wieder gut dabei zu haben
großartig erstens eine tolle bewertung
im zweiten super austria witz danke dass
du da bist revue glaubt daher kann man
schon acht sagen max gerth national der
chef doch gern und er legt einen scheck
über all das sagt ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
707 kraft gibt mir der zehn von zehn
dafür das finde ich krass wisst ihr dass
ich so selbst mich bisher viel
schlechter eingeschätzt habe und j gib
mir dass eine zehn von zehn freut mich
ein bisschen dass geely das denkt
wahrscheinlich genauso confident wie mit
allem max ist ein absoluter social
skills hinaus 10 uhr alle sagen ich bin
besser darin hält sich eigentlich bin
kann man das ist aber das ist voll
aufschlussreich für mich aber jetzt kann
ich mir so denken hey du bist gar nicht
so ein bulli was das angeht sondern
mache einfach bis ihr gut also normal
also macht kann ich mich um geschlecht
also muss ich sagen okay dann
wahrscheinlich kernkraft hey leute ich
firefall nächste frage wie gut sehe ich
aus ich finde überhaupt nicht schlimm zu
sagen dass man findet dass man gut
aussieht weil alle predigen immer selbst
liebe aber sobald man sich selbst gut
findet so dumm sein so natürlich nicht
so kann man absolut sagen erst mal
überlegen was will ich mir selbst geben
also ich mag mich schon schon gerne seht
ich würde mir wahrscheinlich nacht oder
8,5 geben ich gebe mir glaube ich mal
lacht es gibt mir eine 8
würdig eine 95 geben
aber der höhepunkt gibt es 82 sie zu gut
aus und es ist einfach gemein ist
einfach ab ok so eine halbwahrheit
richtige antwort aber trotzdem
oha da kann man da sagen schon auch eine
stabile 890 homo basis wie smoke ihn ist
es ihren bruder dankeschön bis makes me
feel like ich würde sagen max design 830
[Musik]
dank keine lobeshymnen schwingen aber
max ist schon zweiter typisch so 9 aus
zehn war geil ich mich bei allen
bedanken für dieses wunderbare
kompliment und machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten frage es ist dass ich das jetzt
feiert aber ich weiß es folgt die dritte
frage was haltet ihr von meinen
youtube-videos das finde ich es wirklich
sehr interessant weil ich selbst bin
gerade so ein bisschen unzufrieden
möchte mich so ein bisschen erwachsener
werden sage ich mal mit meinem youtube
content also manchmal machen so sachen
weil ich mir so denke es könnte gut
ankommen aber ich muss irgendwie so
richtig die dinge machen so die ich
liebe wissen weil dann wird halt auch
viel mehr videos kommen und so und das
wäre einfach glaube ich viel geiler ich
mag meine videos auf einer skala von
eins bis zehn wahrscheinlich irgendwie
so aktuell wahrscheinlich so ne 6 aber
dieses video mag ich zum beispiel viel
mehr und deshalb will ich mehr in die
richtung machen und ich hoffe es gefällt
euch auch gras ich habe mich nicht
darüber unterhalten mit kelly und sie
sagt genau das was ich gerade gesagt
habe das finde ich richtig nette worte
von kelly auf jeden fall nicht so nicht
mal ansatzweise so lustig wie max im
echten leben ist wirklich krass und
praxis deutlich lustiger
freunde seien also vielleicht lernt ihr
max einfach mal kenntnis und lacht ihr
mehr leute sagen ich bin lustiger und
unterhaltsamer echt leben als in meinen
videos dann muss ich einfach mehr ich
selbst sein vielleicht einmal ein video
sound mag kann auch sehr viel mehr sich
herausholen
nicht nur scheiße sondern noch geile
scheiße wieder so wenige also aber noch
zu wenig darüber müssen wir glaube ich
nicht reden offensichtlich videos und
sonst finde ich finde ich es voll cool
wie lustig und kreativ sondern der
moderation er ist wenn man seine videos
macht und ja ich glaube dass sehr sehr
authentischen sein video solltest du
eigentlich auch oder größtenteils so
auch in kassel das geht jetzt ein
bisschen entgegen dem anderen
die sache ist so wie ich rede und so ist
schon sehr wie ich selbst bin sind halt
nicht so 100 prozent meine interessen
sag ich mal oder nur meine interessen
sondern ich will befinde dann kommt so
ein kompromiss was funktioniert und was
ich will deshalb kann ich es aber auch
voll verstehen was sebastian sein war ja
ich sagen wir auch noch nie ein video
von mir gesehen nehme ich auch überhaupt
nicht übel aber dann kann sie
logischerweise nicht zu der frage sagen
ich finde dass max gefangen ist in
seinem alten youtube ich gras und da
glaube ich verbesserungsbedarf gibt und
das füllt er vielleicht auch ein
bisschen da habe ich
verbesserungsmöglichkeiten da bin ich
super gespannt ich weiß dass jana glaube
ich nicht so gut findet meiner meinung
nach hat max sehr viel mehr potenzial
als dieses classic reaction also youtube
was so also das so nichts persönliches
weißt du ich finde irgendwie der kann
viel interessantere sache machen wäre es
sehr viel intelligenter als so ein
content zu machen
ja leute sind sie echt heftig ich mache
einfach weiter mit der nächsten frage
was ist meine größte schwäche eine
superschwere frage die ich mir aber
schon gestellt habe deshalb kann ich sie
ja denke ich mal schnell beantworten
zumindest das was mir einfällt ich würde
tatsächlich sagen es ist mein unvermögen
sachen durchzuziehen sei es regelmäßige
ablaufs steuerunterlagen suchen sei es
regelmäßig ins fitnessstudio zu gehen
keine ahnung verliere so schnell die
motivation bei sachen und eigentlich
geht es mir dabei gar nicht gut sondern
ich feiere es vielmehr wenn ich sachen
durchziehe ich finde es geil wenn ich
einen vollgepackten tag habe wo ich
morgens aufsteht video aufnehmen
steuerunterlagen mache in der uni war
fitnessstudio wisst ihr danach geht es
mir richtig gut aber irgendwie habe ich
so oft tage wo ich einfach nur chillen
und mich dann richtig gefühle das ist
einfach dumm und das hasse ich an mir
ich weiß nicht ob wir das überhaupt so
mitbekommt aber ich bin schon so jemand
der sich um alle seine freunde und in
seinem leuten in seinem umfeld kümmert
und egal was ich vor ort wenn mich
jemand fragt agency ema helfen kommen so
dann würde ich halt immer so alles
stehen und liegen lassen und den leuten
helfen was halt voll cool ist weil ich
mich freut dass ich ziehe daraus freude
so ich bin gerne zu läuten und macht
ihnen freude das verstehe ich schon auch
dass kelly sagt weil wenn man halt zum
beispiel irgendwie immer die anderen
über sich selbst stellt sodann kommen
auch sehr heftig weiter glauben mag es
ist einfach zu nett kraft einfach zu
nett und das glaube ich manchmal zu viel
mit sich machen zu nett finde ich
interessant ich weiß nicht was seine
größte schwäche ist aber eine schwäche
von ihnen hat ist dass er vielleicht
bisschen zu bequem ist er setze ich
nicht gibt nicht gerne situation wo
ziemlich unangenehm ist weil wir etwas
neues lernt oder sich irgendwie zu
retten und konfessionen rausgeht
bisschen bequemlichkeit geht auch so ein
bisschen die richtung von dem was ich
gesagt habe da hat er auf jeden fall
recht das stimmt schon aber ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich das ändern wollen würde
weil kann also darauf sich halt voll
viel freude dass ich anderen helfe und
für die darin und so wahrscheinlich
sollte ich da vielleicht einen kleinen
kompromiss finden nicht loslassen zu
können so zum beispiel auf partys und so
wenn er in irgendeiner weise
verantwortungsbewusstsein hat wenn wir
beispielsweise bei ihm grillen kann
fährt er keine sekunden runter und sorgt
sich die ganze zeit darum dass es allen
gut geht alle was zu trinken haben alle
was zu essen haben und ich glaube das
schränkt ihnen vielleicht manchmal ein
bisschen ein noch mal ein bisschen
andere antworten sondern ich nicht nicht
loslassen zu können
das ist voll die pno jobs muss ich bin
vor nachdenklich in diesem video sondern
weil diese ganzen infos so ist man ja
nicht gewöhnt dass man also dass man von
sechs leuten so was krasses gesagt
bekommt muss ich mir so drüber
nachdenken ich weiß nicht ob es eine
schwäche ist oder eine stärke
wahrscheinlich manchmal dass einem
manchmal das andere aber wenn leute
seien so hilfe brauchen kann er nicht
gut nein sagen die leute das sagen alle
was ist eure meinung dazu kamen zu nett
sein
ich weiß es nicht und man hat doch
nichts davon wenn man alles für sich
selbst macht jeder gesagt hat jeder
gesagt also ich glaube das kann auch
manchmal eine schwäche sein kann schon
gut sein kann wenn eine sache die ihr
nicht an mir mag was sag ich selbst im
prinzip mag ich logischerweise meine
größte schwäche nicht an mir selbst das
wäre langweilig deshalb sage ich einfach
mal ich kann manchmal wirklich nicht so
gut zu hören ist ihr wenn ich so mit
leuten in längeren gespräch bin oder so
und dann so nicht so weg und dann habe
ich nicht so richtig zugehört und für
mich voll beschissen deshalb aber ist
also wisst ihr also manchmal bin ich ein
schlechter zuhörer
ich weiß es so schwer ich glaube bei
niemandem ist diese fragestellung bei
max
weil er ist voll der gute gastgeber eher
machtvoll viel vereinen erst mega nett
und lieb und hilft einem wenn man was
braucht aber ich glaube was mich stören
würde oder was ich nicht mögen würde
wenn es dazu kommen sollte was er nie
passieren muss dass wir uns mal richtig
streiten würden würde er vielleicht
zeigen so nehme ich möchte nicht
streiten und wir können das alles
anständig ausdiskutieren nicht sondern
safe ich hab's also ich hasse es nicht
zu streiten und deshalb bin ich bei
streits immer so dass sich darüber redet
jemand ich muss nochmal so sauerwein und
einfach so vereint zwei tage und ich
glaube er wäre nicht möchten wir die
staffel streule des todes schwierig
also entweder halt alle sogar gar nichts
jetzt echt überlegen alles
max ist glaube ich manchmal zu ruhig das
ist für eine aussage hat keine ahnung
ich weiß es nicht
wer somit ich finde max übertreiben ein
bisschen mit dem wissen von leuten
dieses wissen so in unserem
freundeskreis so josten wir uns halt
alle weg und auch irgendwelche
unbekannten personen werden also voll
groß sind einfach weil es lustig finden
wir meinen das aber nicht so immer schon
oft das gefühl dass er einfach so laut
ist und zu oft macht also so einfach sie
jetzt mal eigenen verbissen spaßig
gemeint aber ist auch in punkten ernst
aber das feld bisschen torwart kann muss
ich noch mal drüber nachdenken sagt
nicht wir kennen es jetzt noch nicht so
übertrieben gut das stimmt so richtig
kennengelernt haben wir uns eigentlich
erst bei unserem gemeinsamen urlaub auch
voll die bescheuerte aussage ist aber
davor war es immer so gegenseitig sich
mal sehen und auf partys ist nichts
aufgefallen in der zeit in der wir uns
kennengelernt haben ist mir nichts
aufgefallen was ich nicht mag
das ist ein durchaus guter mensch und
diese fragen findet so so gestellt dass
wir nur positive sachen daraus bekommen
gar nicht wahr ich habe mir extra mühe
gegeben dass ich aufs mal also dass die
stress bekommen
[Musik]
das war wirklich ich habe mir wirklich
wollte so
kontroverse aber habe ich auch bekommt
max ist manchmal glaube ich so straight
manchmal möchte ich gerne ausrasten und
max bleibt dann aber doch ein bisschen
ruhig was mir gut tut eben wir das aber
glaube ich gut tun wenn er auch mal ein
bisschen mitzieht und ein bisschen
scheiße baut kann ich sehr gut verstehen
ich bin immer so einer der sagt hey lass
mal nicht so laut nach umwegen nachbarn
so und es fragt mich auch ab aber das
ist ja wieder so ich denke so sehr ein
anderes ist ja wahrscheinlich das was
ich manchmal selber so irgendwann mal
was reitet er sagt ich habe keine muss
der verdienst du hast wirklich dann
keine lust auf videos oder wenn er dann
anfängt zu zocken zockt ihr habt den
ganzen tag durch
vielleicht habe ich auch das
durchhaltevermögen was mir fehlt beim
sachen die mich weiterbringen weiß
angeblich weiter wohin zocken
keine videos machen ist vielleicht war
okay leute das war's vom video muss echt
sagen krasses video für mich die
persönlicher viel interessanter als
meine anderen videos sonst so ich hoffe
wir sehen uns beim nächsten videos
wieder ich habe jetzt ein paar ideen
gesammelt die mir glaube ich echt spaß
machen
wir sehen uns dann bis dahin und tschüss